[Music]
in april this year
the danish beer maker carlsberg put its
reputation on the line
when it launched an advertising campaign
that admitted its beer in britain
wasn't what it was supposed to be
[Music]
it was an admission that could only come
as a result of a profound
change in the culture of the company
brought about by
this man case to heart a dutchman
with a reputation for forging unity from
division
well when i came in this business i
started to talk with
many people i think i had 200 interviews
and
everybody more or less said the same
this is a siloed company
i'm david tweed this is bloomberg
turnaround join me to see
how ceo case to heart put the froth
back into carlsberg
[Music]
when case de hard arrived to carlsberg
in 2015
he found a company demoralized by a
badly timed investment in the russian
market
that had forced it to stand on the
sidelines of a wave of brewing industry
consolidation
what is special about the casper
turnaround is really how
case-to-heart has triggered the
turnaround by returning the company
to its original purpose that the founder
set out
and really engaging the workforce when i
think back to
2015 i suppose what for me was very
different about carlsberg versus today
was i don't think we had any real
clarity on the way forward we looked at
our competitors
we looked at the industry consolidation
that was happening and was happening
pretty fast
at that time and there was a lot of
concern about the future
now what is the carlsberg 1883 when i
met case to heart i wanted to ask
how do you deal with all these issues at
once we
put it together in the strategy which is
called sale22 so we have the
a seven year program if you like a start
of a journey
on the other hand we realized ourselves
together with our top people that we
didn't have the money
to do the journey so we said okay let's
do two things
we create the future with for ourselves
and that's then called cell 32 but we
front our own journey
reluctant to our shareholders for funds
to hard adopted a
cut costs and investor savings in
premium brand strategy
the plan addressed the concerns that had
prompted the carlsberg foundation which
has controlled the brewer since 1876
to seek out a new chief executive in the
first place
the brewer's debt had been mounting
turnover and profit was down
stemming from the decision in 2008 to
take full control of baltica
russia's leading beer brand a move that
turned
spectacularly sour because after that
deal
russia accounted for a third of
carlsberg's revenues
just as a countrywide alcoholism
epidemic
prompted the government to crack down on
sales and increase
taxes on beer by 200
in 2014 another blow international
sanctions after russia's incursion into
ukraine
undermined its economy carlsberg's
eastern european sales
slumped it meant that as the margins
declined
and as the overall profitability
declined
they were unable to react in that market
and
then it removed any firepower for them
to participate in significant m
a in other markets or even to support
other markets with with the kind of
marketing spend that would be required
versus
very strong and very deep pocketed
competitors
that wave of mergers and acquisitions
had led to the creation of companies
like anheuser-busch inbev
or abi a brewing behemoth
nine times carlsberg's size
the first leg of the turnaround was
called funding the journey
the idea was to cut costs to free up
cash to invest in the growth leg of the
turnaround
dub sale 22. breweries were closed in
russia and china
to get rid of excess capacity supply
chains revamped to strip out costs
the results can be seen in a net debt to
earnings chart
it peaks in 2008 the purchase of the
russian brewery
it drops onto hart's 2015 appointment as
his cost savings
are used to pay off debt and his
investments in brands
improve earnings it's all about
basically taking the cost out
of the business so that you could then
release
cash to invest in the core bus in the
core brands
uh also reduce your debt from is around
about three times
that a bit down when he came in so you
could reduce that debt and actually
release cash to do in
m a
the funding the journey program it's not
something that was finite
carlsberg is continually striving to cut
costs
and improve efficiencies which is why
this machine
here has just had its head redesigned so
it can pick up
not just one but two of carlsberg's
newest products
the draftmaster
and this is a draft master it's a new
type of lightweight keg
but it's still pretty heavy what's
really interesting is
that all of the production of this type
of keg is done in this plant instead of
all around europe
they bring the beer in it turns out it's
much cheaper
and it's still part of funding the
journey
the second leg of the turnaround sale 22
is a five-year plan designed to generate
sales growth through investment in
premium brands
as well as specialty and no alcohol
beers
the impact can be seen here last year
the value of sales increased 6.5 percent
while beer volumes climbed just under
five percent
carlsberg is selling more expensive beer
this strategy can be seen directly in
the real and projected gains in earnings
per share
and a share price near record levels
carlsberg
has taken out a lot of cost through the
funding the journey
program and then they've used that money
to invest
into growth into really moving the
company up
up market again and really get back to a
winning streak
coming up to hart tells me the
combination of funding the journey and
sale 22 would have been impossible to
achieve
without a significant management shaker
cutting cost is not an inspirational
thing but that we cut
cost in order to reinvest in the
business and give something back as well
to the shareholder that was i think a
[Music]
trigger
cognizant that carlsberg needed to
invest and loathe to ask shareholders to
forego dividends
case to heart came up with a two-pronged
turnaround strategy
but he had to get senior management on
board
he brought and built clarity
around the strategy around how he saw us
growing
and how he saw us funding that growth in
a way that was stretching but everyone
felt was realistic
i think the other part of that was the
way that he did that it wasn't a top
down he didn't come in and say i've got
the answers he came in
and engaged the top 60 and spoke to them
and asked them for their ideas and they
had to
create the strategy with him
the top 60 are the leaders of the
countries and the leaders of the
functions
and they were together and basically we
said look we have an issue here we
have dissatisfied shareholders
we look at our feedback of our people
they're not satisfied
our supervisory board is not satisfied
our customers have the feel that we
don't come with the right brews and
innovation and so on so really we have
an issue
and i'm not going to solve that issue
for you we are going to solve that issue
and that means that we are going to
co-create
the future pretty shocking pretty
shocking for a lot of those people in
the room
how many of those top 60 then
in 2015 are still in the top 60.
yeah i raised that question uh of course
i knew who were new but
we were in december 2018
in belgium in greenberg where one of our
weeds is coming from
and there were 22
hands up at the moment that i asked who
was
with us about a third about a third so
that's a pretty
telling statistic you've had a pretty
big turnover at the top in the managers
now they haven't necessarily left
carlsberg but uh i think most of them
did right we started really from the top
so we really started with
the executive committee and at the
moment you start to bring in new people
in your executive committee they start
as well to work with people they really
feel can do
the work for the future and and change
people
[Music]
i want to show you this carlsberg
building because it's very special it's
built around an old silo
in the middle part there are no windows
so that becomes a sort of
void but it's more than a symbolic void
it's a
physical void case to heart's office
when he became ceos on the top floor
and he used to say to his staff i could
die up here and no one would find me for
three days because no one's walking past
so what he's done is he's moved his
office from the top floor
down to the second floor that means he's
in the thick of it
he's collaborating he's communicating to
heart is taking his move from the top
floor to the second floor
one big step further a completely new
headquarters
it will be over there in q1 2020 but
then we will be in a totally new office
where everybody has open office
there are only four floors in total and
the consequence of that is that we will
all mingle together
and by that i think there will be much
more
energy in the business or even more
energy in the business people come in
and see that it's a contemporary
business that's not
what the kind of feel you have at the
moment you step in now
one of the other concerns at the
carlsberg foundation was that the
company had veered from the vision
laid out by the founder j.c jacobson in
the 19th century
that profits of the company would be
channeled to support
art science and culture
the little mermaid is the number one
tourist attraction in copenhagen
commissioned by carlsberg carl jacobson
the son of the founder
fell in love with the story by hans
christian anderson
about a mermaid who gave up everything
in order to be able to swim to the
surface
and be with her beloved but then she
died
but the link with carlsberg goes on
because carlsberg foundation
is still funding the arts here in
denmark
carl jacobson founded the glypto ticket
a museum devoted to sculpture in
downtown copenhagen that was packed the
day i visited
and it was this contribution to society
the foundation's
purpose that fleming bezenbacher wanted
to nurture
when he was looking for a new chief
executive what was it about
case to heart that made you think that
he was going to be a fit for
carlsberg and also the objectives of the
foundation
why did i take him well i think first of
all case had done
a fantastic turnaround in fishlane
campina
and i could see a turnaround voice also
needed in carlsberg
between 2009 and 2015 to heart had
presided over the successful integration
of two dutch dairy cooperatives which
before the merger
had considered themselves to be virtual
enemies but also from talking to him he
specifically said to me if i take this
job i do not take it only if this was an
ordinary job just to create value for
shareholders
i've been used to work for farmers in
the netherlands
if i take this job i would like to work
for scientists in denmark
you know with the foundation and so
forth here also
was willing to focus on the purpose also
willing to focus on sustainability
[Music]
one of the things about carlsberg that
i've been hearing a lot about is
purpose-driven leadership
now can you explain what is that about
what is it
well basically it comes back to why why
would you
come to the office uh what is basically
you think
that you and your colleagues uh can
contribute not only to the business but
maybe a broader perspective as well so
it comes
and that's where we started what is the
the what the how and the why
many companies start with the y but we
were finding that a bit difficult to
find
the the y at the beginning had it been
lost the y in
carlsberg we think so and it took me
personally almost 9 months
to 12 months to really find the why
what about your own journey in
leadership
well i think the biggest decision in my
life was to move out of hr
the point that really made me think
was having an uh an exit
talk with a person that needed to be
fired
i was as old as my father and the
decision was not taken by myself so i
i was if you like literally almost the
executor and i thought this is not
um i would like to to spend my life to
execute things that other people have
uh have decided um and then i
started to feel like how will i come to
well
maybe not ceo of a company but in
leadership roles and the universe that
was very much
via marketing so i moved from hr to
marketing
and then moved the ladder to general
management one of the things i've heard
you describing
um your management team is is like a
football
team and not everyone's a striker it is
head office against
the countries it's marketing against
sale it's finance again the rest
the rest of the world so it felt a bit
like this is a company let's say that we
have 30
countries that we are playing on 30
different soccer fields
and one of the first pictures i showed
to people so well we are now
all playing in different teams on
different soccer fields
we are now in in the future one team and
that means
that we have the guys in the in the
countries they are the strikers
they need to score the goals that means
as well that they need to know
everything about the consumer and the
customer
in their country then we have a few
midfielders
supply chain group commercial these are
the people that need to make the plans
passing the ball if you like or the
plans at the right moment with the right
specs at someone's fought but they are
not
scoring the goals and every people on
the defense like hr and finance and
legal and they need to make sure that we
then make
big mistakes or develop our people and
so sport
coming up more from case to heart and
the uk advertising campaign
and what it tells you about the new
carlsberg
[Music]
so why don't we have a beer yeah let's
do that
[Music]
when case to heart joined carlsberg he
launched a dual recovery plan
savings and growth there was also
cultural change
and that's where carlsberg's purpose
statement comes in
i started to talk about uh that we brew
for better today
and then basically we talked about the
the quality and the brews
and basically that we needed to perform
better but as well about
the future we we set at a certain moment
we brew for better today
and tomorrow
[Music]
in april this year to heart showed he
was prepared to walk the walk in one of
carlsberg's
key 18 western european markets
in britain carlsberg was traditionally
made with a 3.8
alcohol content lower than elsewhere
where the taste was richer
and as more craft beers came into the uk
market
tastes evolved leaving carlsberg's brew
behind eurena golfman worked on the
strategy for carlsberg's advertising
agency in london
we realized that the market was starting
to shift and
people's tastes and priorities and
pallets
were changing people were demanding
better quality beer
so it wasn't as much about consuming
loads and loads of it
it was about consuming beer that you
thought was of good quality
and we realized that carlsberg had
started to suffer from a perception
issue
first and foremost it's like drinking
the
bath water your nan died in
carlsberg announced it had changed its
beer and introduced new carlsberg
in the british market it was a brave
campaign because you have to admit your
mistakes and
uh in the uk market anyway the the
carlsberg brand was probably
thought of as a mainstream brand rather
than premium and it's premium everywhere
else in europe and that is the way they
want to take the beer
and the beer suffered danish superstar
mads mikkelsen told the uk audience that
we danes don't cry into our beer
we focus on brewing a better one brewing
for better today that means that we're
never satisfied with what we have
and that's i think what we recognized in
the uk maybe the consumer was earlier
than we did because
we saw our market share declining and
that means that
the customer and the consumers don't
like your brand anymore so we [ __ ]
into that
to that and then we looked at the the
brews and
we improved if you look at the recent
advert in the uk
where they they said carlsberg you know
probably not the best
the best beer almost um being
self-deprecating regarding
what had been a platform of their their
advertising for
for years then that that really
indicates a flexible mindset towards
towards brands and a recognition that
you need
portfolios that satisfy the needs of
local consumers in
in individual markets
[Music]
to heart's efforts to return to the
scientific underpinnings of the founder
are felt here
in the carlsberg research laboratory
which over the years has delivered
breakthroughs such as the first
cultivation of pure yeast
and the invention of the ph scale
and so these are all the brews well
these are actually when people have been
employed with carlsberg or here in the
casper laboratory for more than 25 years
then you get your own bottle oh yeah and
look
here's mine oh it's a big one it looks
like shampoo yeah
and there was a beautiful you know wheat
passion fruit
oh very nice tell me more about what's
happened since
uh since we've seen case to heart come
to uh to carlsberg because
i believe there's there's been more
integration
i think there has been a lot of
integration and there has been a lot
more of
agility but also i would say that you
know here from an
research point of view we have been very
much integrated now into the whole
business and
especially into all the strategic
priorities for cell 22
really how so well i think you know we
have a lot of focus now on really
supporting the strategic areas
like cold beer making a difference in
that craft and speciality
non-alcoholic beer and here the research
laboratory can really support a lot
with completely new types of yeast
strains producing normal alcohol
and there are also other types of yeast
strain that can give a consumer benefit
better taste experience aromas and so on
and that plays into sales 22 because
it's got the focus on core beer but also
new products yes
it does very much so again i would say
we are
today very very much on the agenda in
you know the whole commercial agenda and
we are today
very much in front also you know when we
have commercial meetings and when we
have visitors and so on
so again i think that's also the history
of the laboratory
kallsberg has quite a unique history
when it comes to
research and science and especially also
having the more
fundamental science which was founded
here in the laboratory
one of carlsberg's key areas for growth
is asia
the driver of its most recent revenue
gains particularly where we see a lot of
growth coming from is in premiumization
so driving uh into more premium
categories more premium brands
and that's really been a fantastic
driver for us in china
for instance where we have a good
geographic footprint and some very
strong positions in some specific
markets but we're really looking to
expand beyond those
and to launch into new cities and to
particularly launch with
the more premium brands in the portfolio
since 2014
carlsberg's increased its share of the
premium market in china
to 14 from nine percent while abi's
share has dropped to 43
[Music]
china helped drive a 9.5 increase in
carlsberg's
2019 first quarter beverage sales in
asia
which now accounts for a third of
carlsberg's total beverage sales
still abi represents a threat alongside
heineken which last year struck a
partnership deal with china's biggest
brewer
you know china as a sake house book i've
done a very good job
there but you would imagine that in the
areas of
and channels in china where carlsberg
have been doing well
there will be competitive pressures
coming in
carlsberg is well aware of the
competitive challenges it faces
but even so to hear it from the people i
talked to at carlsberg during my visit
there
case to heart seems to have succeeded in
injecting a new sense of
yes i'll use his word purpose into the
company
the question is how to keep the momentum
going
by renewing ourselves if you like
setting the sales
tweaking it making sure that we keep our
speed
uh having three times a year the top 60
being self-critical on are we really
delivering
maybe sometimes being a bit paranoid as
well about whether the wind is coming
from another side than we expected
whether the rays are a bit higher than
we forecasted
these kind of things and the top team is
really very good at that
what advice would you give to another
chief executive
who was looking at a company that also
needs to be turned around
plan for the worst and don't over
promise
[Music]
you